one month after flooding hit Boone
children are catching up on their
schoolwork
the flooding disrupted their education
for weeks
I've never seen flooding like that
before I've heard it last happened 50
years ago the nearby River made it worse
and it's difficult for us to put
measures in place because we cannot
predict how bad these natural weather
events will be across Mozambique
schooling for close to 5 million
children has been affected
more than 800 children at this school
had just started the school year and
Cyclone pretty hit the flooding impacted
the already limited resources and now
exams have had to be postponed while Aid
agencies have assisted in building
climate resilient classrooms most
schools don't have them
others have had to make do with
temporary shelters in zambezio Province
more than 1 000 classrooms have had
their teaching disrupted also large
swathes of farms were washed away which
the United Nations says is likely to
lead to food shortages for children who
are already vulnerable to malnourishment
and diseases like cholera and malaria
well I think for a country like
Mozambique which is hit year after year
by these tropical storms tropical
Cyclones
um a country where many much of the
infrastructure is is not particularly
strong
um it like I said it really shows the
importance of investing in climate
resilient infrastructure which will
stand up uh it costs a little bit more
in the short term but in the long term
the value of that investment pays off
for now the UN says it needs 89 million
dollars to respond to the immediate
education and health needs of children
affected by the most recent flooding
in the long term there are worries that
worsening weather conditions will impact
years worth of education for millions of
children
Al Jazeera buana Mozambique